Bill und Giese sind sehr am Tag der Sauer, meistens sind nicht wirklich Schärf über die Mord.
Ja, wir machen Schau, jetzt die Podcasts, fahr, roh und auch vielleicht kommt jetzt für uns die Mord. Vielen, vielen Dank. Ich bin auf beeindruckend. Solchen Leuten kann man vertrauen. Stefan, was ist los? Ich bin auf Stefan.de.
Wem gehört Stefan?
Es ist die gruseligste Seite der Welt.
Stefan.de ist die gruseligste Website der ganzen Welt.
Holy Grail!
Ich habe jetzt mit vielem gerechnet, aber nicht damit. Also erstmal ein gruseliges Bild, ein androgynes Mischwesen, man weiss nicht genau, ob Mann oder Frau schaut uns an in so einem Horror.
Keine Ahnung, das ist ganz gruselig.
Und dann kannst du auf verschiedene Reiter klicken, auf verschiedene Links innerhalb der Website.
Lonely, Fast, Beautiful, Sexy und Dark.
Und auf allen Bildern, es sind so verschiedene Kunst, also so kunstdrucke wie bild also einfach bilder digitale bilder aber ganz ganz gruselige rein aber ach so jetzt verstehe ich es erst aber offen das scheint ein fotograf zu sein oder ein künstler aber interessant aber ich finde auch die beschreibung wenn man sich mit attributen beschreiben müsste und das Das erste ist einsam und das zweite ist schnell. Ja, einsam und schnell.
Und schnell einsam und das zweite ist schnell.
Ich bin einsam und schnell.
Und schnell einsam auch. Also, man kann mich nicht lange alleine lassen. Ich bin schnell einsam, aber dafür beautiful, sexy und dark. Wollen wir ganz kurz das Podcast UFO-Webzeitentipp der Woche machen? Ja. Ja, diese Woche.
Übrigens, Florentin.de ist noch nicht vergeben, glaube ich. Also da kannst du mal versuchen, dich reinzuhängen. Nein, das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen. Wobei ich würde auch sagen, Leander ist fast noch häufiger als Florentin. Also leander.de gesichert zu haben, finde ich ganz toll. Mittlerweile werden Instagram-Handles ja auch doll gedealt. Also wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel adfin oder so hat, ist das schon krass. Und dann kriegt man auch viel Geld von zum Beispiel Finnland geboten wahrscheinlich, um Adfin bei Instagram zu bekommen. Also ich glaube, Adtim hat ihn ein Deutscher gehabt, der hat sehr viel Geld dafür geboten bekommen, weiß ich nicht genau. Auf jeden Fall sehr interessant. Ja, das ist eine gute Idee. OG-Handles heißen die dann so auf Instagram, wenn du Dog oder so hast als Instagram-Name, dann kann das ganz viel wert sein. Und aber mach dich auch angreifbar, weil es gibt viele Hacker, die dann versuchen, dich zu hacken, dass sie dir den abnehmen und dann weiterverkaufen können. Gibt es tolle Berichte aus dem beliebten Internet-Podcast Reply All. Da gab es eine Instagram- oder ich glaube Snapchat-Userin, die hatte den Namen Lizard und dann wurde sie gehackt. Ach was. Weil Hacker an ihren Ad-Handle Snapchat-Namen rankommen wollten, um den zu verkaufen. Sehr gut. Was ist denn dein Webseiten-Tipp? Aber gut, dass du es gesagt hast mit florentin.de, die werde ich mir auf jeden Fall holen. Obwohl hier kommt man auf heisst es florentin.de ist nicht sicher, wo ich sage, ja gut getroffen. Oh, mir kommt 404 Seite nicht gefunden. Oh, ich bin in Chrome und da kommt erst Florentin.de ist nicht sicher, wo ich sage, ja, gut getroffen eigentlich. Oh, bei mir kommt Fehler 404 Seite nicht gefunden. Oh, ich bin in Chrome und da kommt erst Florentin.de ist nicht sicher. Dann geh mal in Safari, Safari ist alles scheißegal. Das ist mein... Warum ist eine 404 Seite unsicher? Heisst 404 einfach nicht, dass da nichts ist? Wie kann nichts gefährlich sein? Naja, das ist eine sehr spannende Frage, die ich gerne an die Programmierer von Safari weiterleiten würde, denen offensichtlich alles scheissegal ist. Wo ich auch glaube, dass sie das Gefühl haben, 4.04 ist sehr sicher, weil da halt nichts ist. Die haben halt unterschiedliche Antworten auf die gleiche Frage, finde ich auch interessant. Es ist eine tief philosophische Frage, wie man mit dem Nichts umgeht. Also ist es etwas, womit man sich beschäftigen sollte oder nicht oder wo man eingesaugt werden kann? Also ich finde es gut, dass diese philosophische Tradition zwischen Heidegger und Hegel sich auch in die moderne Welt übertragen hat und Chrom und Farida unterschiedliche. Ich bin ganz gespannt, was Mozilla sagt. Man fragt sich immer, warum steht man Philosophie, was soll das? Aber nein, es sind ganz konkrete Fragen 404. Richtig, nur halt mit, wir haben andere Diskurse, mit von anderen Diskursteilnehmern heutzutage. Aber was ist denn dein Webseitentipp? Ich habe meinen bereits ausgewählt. Achso, du hast Stefan die Ausgabe, oder was? Nee, ich habe einen neuen, einen richtigen. Soll ich zuerst? Oh, da bin ich jetzt gar nicht drauf vorbereitet. Okay, und zwar ist mein
Website ein Tipp der Woche,
hackertyper.net
und zwar gibt es mal alle einen kurz
h-a-c-k
oder zekka, wie wir
im Ruhrgebiet immer gesagt haben,
e-r-t-y-p-e-r
.net, Hackertyper
und du hast einfach eine schwarze Website und du kannst einfach Tasten, schnell Tasten eingeben. Und es sieht so aus, als ob du ganz schnell irgendeinen neongrünen Hacker Code in die Matrix, im Prinzip sieht es aus, als ob du die Matrix schreibst. Und das ist total geil. Vor allem bei langen Zugfahrten mache ich das sehr gerne. Ich höre einfach Musik oder ein lustiges Hörbuch, so die Schlümpfe, die Schlümpfe drei. Und dabei tippe ich aber ganz schnell auf mein Wie wild und manisch auf meinen Laptop ein. Und ich freue mich da immer über Direktionen neben mir. Es denken immer alle, dass ich mich in den ICE reinhecke. Und du kannst auch lustige Späße machen. Wenn es irgendwie heisst, wir haben einen Stellwerk-Schaden oder sowas, dann sagst du, na, einen Moment. Dann machst du Hackerteile auf.
So einer bist du?
Ich schaue dann einfach mal kurz ein paar Zahlen ein und dann geht der Zug wieder los und links neben mir der Mann mit dem Aktenkoffer, der die ganze Zeit weggenickt war, aber dann sich wütend aufgerichtet hat, weil der Zugverspielung hat, sieht dann, ich habe den repariert und freut sich dann für mich.
So kriegt man vielleicht einen Kaffee ausgegeben.
Ich finde es ganz toll. Es ist eine Website, die suggeriert, dass man ein sehr guter Coder wäre. Ich finde es eine fantastische Idee. Mega gut, finde ich eine richtig gute Idee und vielleicht wurde auch so Safari geschrieben, also wer weiß, vielleicht ist das auch in der Informatikszene mittlerweile angekommen.
Ich weiss auch gar nicht, was das für ein Code ist, ob das einfach immer generischer Code ist oder ob man damit wirklich eine Website theoretisch bauen könnte, wenn man das irgendwo eingibt. Ich glaube, es ist generisch.
Ich habe einen Webseitentipp, der ein kleines Puzzlestück ist in meiner langen, langen Geschichte.
Ich habe eine lange Quest, die ich seit Jahren verfolge, denn, ich gebe es zu, ich bin Downloader.
Ich bin einer von diesen Downloadern, von denen man so viel hört, und zwar von YouTube-Videos. Das darf man nicht sagen, glaube ich. Ich downloade YouTube-Videos, weil ich bin auch ein Zugmensch, die Gleise sind mein Horizont, mein Zelt, mein Herz, meine Heimat. Moment, aber wenn die Gleise dein Horizont sind, aber viel nach rechts und links schaust du dann nicht, ne, also du kannst jetzt nicht, oder, also die Weggleisung, also wer ist denn die Weggleisung in deinem Leben und willst du überhaupt mal nach rechts und links abbiegen oder treibst du einfach da hinten, wo sich der Weg hin, ich finde die Metapher sehr spannend, Gleise für sein Leben zu wählen. Ja, mein Scheideweg ist immer Hamm. Und wenn ich immer sage, man hat eine schwere Entscheidung vor sich, sage ich auch, ja, da bist du jetzt in einer echten Hamm-Suche. Zugteil und Hamm. Ja, genau. Da hast du jetzt echt einen grossen Hamm vor dir für eine schwere Entscheidung. Was? Ja, also in der Bahner-Szene spricht sich das langsam rum, aber auch die ist mit Verspätung unterwegs. Und da gibt es natürlich eine lange und lange Tradition an YouTube-Downloadern, weil ich habe so ein bisschen das Gefühl, das ist so ein Wettrüsten. Und zwar immer, wenn irgendein YouTube-Video-Downloader-Dienst zu populär wird, wird der irgendwie beendet von YouTube. Weil YouTube möchte anscheinend nicht, dass die Videos runtergeladen werden. Und deswegen sind die immer nach einer Zeit irgendwie wieder unnutzbar. Und deswegen muss man immer wieder sich was Neues suchen. Ich habe jetzt sogar so eine Terminal-Installation, dass du im Terminal, also bei Mac-Rechnern kann man da halt so Code eingeben, wenn man fancy ist, wenn man nicht auf die kleinen bunten Buttons klicken will, sondern es irgendwie mit so fancy Befehlen seine Programme aufrufen will, kann man sowas Terminal machen. Showoff ist das. Aber es macht auch Spaß, es macht auch Spaß. Ich gebe da teilweise random Sachen ein. Es ist so ein bisschen wie, wenn du kein Internet hast, aber trotzdem Hackartype.com benutzen willst. Dann nimmst du das Terminal auf und gibst einfach ein und einfach Command not found, Command not found, Command not found, Command not found. Mit dem Unterschied, dass wirklich was schief gehen kann, dass du wirklich massiv was kaputt machen kannst. Ja, absolut. Aber das macht spannend. Ich habe tatsächlich mal mit meinem Musikunterricht einen Film gedreht, glaube ich in der achten Klasse oder so, da sollten wir einen Film drehen, und da gab es auch eine Hacker-Szene, und dann haben wir auch einfach das Terminal aufgerufen und ganz schnell was eingetippt und halt jede zweite Zeile war Command not found, Command not found. Das, was natürlich in unserer Kamera niemand gesehen hat, aber in einem Film stelle ich es mir so vor, er war der inkompetenteste Hacker aller Zeiten. Ja, aber sein Blick sagt, er hat es gleich raus. Ja, genau. Sein Blick sagt, er ist drin. Generell, die besten Sachen passieren immer bei einem Dreh, sorry, ganz kurzer Exkurs, aber passieren immer, eigentlich während man filmt, gibt es ja auch diese toll, es gibt irgendwann mal, wo das veröffentlicht, was Hermine Granger hat, der wirklich mit der Feder gemalt, bei Snape im Unterricht damals, also Emma Watson, die Hermine spielt, hat wirklich was aufgeschrieben, während Snape vorhin unterrichtet hat. Und irgendwann hat man das mal gezeigt. Und ich habe auch ab und zu Komparsen mein iPad gegeben, die im Hintergrund erst für die zweite Staffel, die im Hintergrund irgendwie mit dem iPad was machen sollten. Und natürlich habe ich es aufgehoben, was die auf dem iPad gemalt haben.
Das muss ich dann nachher mal veröffentlichen.
Aber so Komparsen machen Scheiss während des Drehs ist immer sehr spannend, weil die
sitzen einfach acht Stunden mit diesem iPad und machen halt Quatsch damit.
Und das habe ich natürlich aufgehoben.
Ja, das ist sehr schön.
Es gibt ja auch oft so diese, also ich glaube, ich habe in meinem Leben noch nicht viele
Sachen gedreht, aber was ich glaube ich schon zehnmal gedreht habe, ist dieses investigative Recherche, irgendwie so ganz viele Bilder an der Wand und dann so eines verbinden mit dem anderen, in einem Buch nachschlagen, etwas niederschreiben, das habe ich schon so oft gedreht, dass jedes Mal, wenn wir sowas drehen, irgendwie für Neomagazine-Spieler, sage ich immer, müssen wir das wirklich drehen oder könnt ihr nicht aus den anderen Sachen, die wir gedreht haben, was Neues zusammenschneiden?
Wir müssen es nicht mehr liebfaken. Es gibt es einfach schon.
Nicht wirklich.
Es gibt es schon.
Es gibt es einfach schon. Und da muss man dann auch viel tippen. Und ich schreibe auch immer ganz, ganz viele Sachen und das habe ich teilweise auch mal kopiert, weil man da teilweise gerade in so einer freien Assoziation, wenn man nichts Schreiben, nichts Sinnvolles schreiben muss, man oft Dinge einfach so einen Gedankenstrom schreibt, der irgendwie dann
doch relativ ergiebig ist, wenn man sich das wieder anschaut, wenn man einfach sagt,
schreib einfach mal 20 Minuten, tipp einfach mal irgendwas und man schreibt ja Wörter,
weil man will ja auch, dass es realistisch aussieht und nicht einfach dieses klassische
linke Hand, rechte Hand, linke Hand, rechte Hand tippen, wo jeder sieht, das ist unrealistisch.
Aber das ist interessant.
Genau, du warst aber gerade woanders, unser Exkurs. Wir sind in Hamm wieder falsch abgebogen. Ja, ich bin ein Downloader. Ja, du bist ein Downloader. Ich bin ein Downloader. Eine Seite wird tatsächlich immer sehr populär, das stimmt. Aber ich habe die Erfahrung gemacht, dass die alle gleich schlecht sind und dadurch auch alle gleich gut. Also einer ist so gut wie der andere. Ich gebe einfach immer YouTube-Downloader ein und der erste Link, der meistens schon so lila hinterlegt ist, weil ich da schon mal draufgeklickt habe, der wird es dann meistens.
Ja, es ist immer so ein Auf und Ab in meinem Leben. Es gibt ja auch einzelne Programme, Clip Grab habe ich zum Beispiel lange benutzt, wo man dann einfach die URL reinkopiert und dann lädt man runter. Aber dann kam irgendwann mal eine Fehlermeldung, Video Not Found. Und dann kam die immer häufiger. Und dann habe ich gemerkt, dass manche Kanäle, also alle Videos von diesem Kanal, diese Fehlermeldung erzeugen. Da dachte ich, okay, die haben vielleicht beim Upload irgendwas so Copyright mässig eingegeben, dass es dann indirekt dazu führt, dass es nicht runtergeladen werden kann oder irgendwas. Oder sie haben es monetarisiert oder nicht monetarisiert. Ich dachte, es liegt am Kanal. Aber irgendwann hat sich das immer weiter ausgebreitet. Und mittlerweile kann ich fast gar nichts mehr runterladen. Und ich denke, dass sie vielleicht entweder das irgendwie von YouTube-Seite irgendwie blockieren und das dann erst auf grossen Kanälen eingeführt haben. Ich weiß es nicht. Es ist eine ganz dunkle Welt. Es ist so wie so Spionage, Gegenspionage, so ein ganzer geheimer Krieg, der im Hintergrund stattfindet zwischen YouTube und YouTube-Downloadern. Von dem wir gar nichts erfahren. Von dem wir nichts erfahren. Man sieht immer nur so bröckchenweise, bis da irgendwann mal die Akten freigegeben werden. Genau, wir sehen nur die Oberfläche. Darüber würde ich gerne mal so eine True-Crime-Serie machen. Würde ich gerne eine Rema machen. Ich würde, weil True-Crimes haben immer so diese krassen Stakes. Dieses Mann hat 380 Leute umgebracht. Ich finde mal eine True-Crime-Serie über diese kleinen Dinge. Über so, jemand hat eine zweite YouTube-Grabber-Website aufgemacht und die wurde nach zwei Tagen übernommen von einem, was darf er machen, schafften eigentlich hinter, wer steckt eigentlich hinter, wer steckt hinter Clip-Grab, den grossen Machern, weißt du, das würde mich immer interessieren, darüber würde ich gerne mal so eine reißerische, zehnteilige, einmal eine Stunde True-Crime-Serie machen. Vor allem, ich bin ja gross Clip-Rap-Fan, so weit sogar, dass ich das Unmögliche getan habe. Ich habe dem Entwickler, Programmierer Geld gespendet. Und das ist ja oft so, wenn du dir so kostenlose Software runterlädst und dann so, hey, geben Sie einen Spendenbetrag ein und du halt, lass mich raten, ich spende null Euro. Hier, ich gebe Ihnen null, bitteschön. Und da habe ich tatsächlich Geld gespendet an Philipp Schmieder und das war nämlich immer so ein Punkt, weil eigentlich haben ja diese Downloader immer so einen Schmuddel-Charakter irgendwie so, ja man, so Pirate Bay, man lädt sich da was runter, aber mich hat beeindruckt bei Clip Grabduster der dass da der Name des Entwicklers steht, wo ich mir einfach dachte, das ist schon Potzblitz, weil YouTube kann den ja jagen und kalt machen, wie auch immer dem den Stecker ziehen, ich weiß nicht genau, was man da für Werte benutzt, aber deswegen dachte ich immer, okay, gut, das ist ein respektables Unternehmen, weil der stellt sich diesem Krieg, also der ist einer der Namen, der in diesem Krieg immer wieder auftaucht, vielleicht könnte man mal eine Doku über den machen, vielleicht hört er auch diesen Podcast, melde dich und erklär uns von diesem Krieg, der stattfindet, warum kann man auf Clip Grab nicht mehr so viele Videos runterladen? Ja, okay, ich hab gerade mal gegoogelt, Philipp Schmider ist tatsächlich der Erfinder von ClipGrab, hat es programmiert und ein Personal Trainer in Köln.
Also entweder ist er der coolste Typ der Welt oder es sind zwei verschiedene Menschen. Mega gut, vielleicht kriegen wir den echt in Podcast oder vielleicht kann er uns einen kurzen Beitrag schicken, was da passiert. Die große Programmierschule mal, weil ich kann das gar nicht. Und ehrlich gesagt, glaube ich, könnte ich das, glaube ich, okay.
Und es hätte vor allem sehr viel Spaß daran.
Ich glaube, es ist auch gut fürs Gehirn, weil du so viele kleine Probleme lösen musst. Also Programmieren ist was, was man eigentlich mal lernen sollte, wo ich wirklich gar nichts von weg habe, wo man so viel Zeit ja auch in der digitalen Welt verbringt. Und das fände ich mal spannend, wenn man da mal vielleicht so einen kleinen Crashkurs bekäme. Von dem grossen Clip-Grab-Macher Philipp Schmmieder. Mach das mal. Aber wie gesagt, ich musste Clip-Grab leider hinter mir lassen, weil es nicht mehr funktioniert hat. Und das ist so, es ist traurig, es ist so ein Abschied, du musst einfach weiterziehen zur nächsten Plattform. Dann habe ich wie gesagt lange diesen Terminalbefehl benutzt, YouTube-DL Download und dann musst du den richtigen Code eingeben und die URL und dann kannst du auch eintippen. Den richtigen Code. Ja, du musst dann die Qualität selber eintippen, in welcher Qualität es runtergeladen werden soll, dann kannst du noch spezifizieren, welcher Bereich des Videos runtergeladen wird und ganz verrückt. Also ich fühle mich jedes Mal wie Bill Gates, wenn ich da tippe und denke mir so und dann so execute und ich hau auf Enter und es Kommand nachfauen. Er fühlt sich wie Bill Gates, nur in Arm, weil er könnte das video einfach selber produzieren nach produzieren ja das stimmt ja und jetzt habe ich eine neue website gefunden und zwar heisst die achtung youtube pp punkt kommen und der gag ist dass über jedem youtube video also das youtube video slash watch ist gleich irgendwas und dann gibst du einfach hinter dem youtube das das PP ein und kommst automatisch auf die Seite, auf der du dieses Video runterladen kannst.
Und auch da, das ging für ein paar Monate und jetzt geht es wieder nicht. Ich weiß nicht, was da los ist, aber irgendwas, ich weiß nicht, ob sich da irgendwie FBI oder NSA genau bei mir eingehackt hat, weil vielleicht haben die mal so eine Datenbankerhebung gemacht, so die intensivsten Downloader der Welt und ich war einfach mit grossem Abstand auf eins und die haben sich gesagt, wir hängen uns einfach an den. Aber das denke ich mir auch manchmal. Das ist vielleicht selektive Wahrnehmung, aber das hatte ich mal, es ist ein bisschen unangenehm, aber bei einem Porno, also mehrere Male, dass ich dann, sobald ich jemanden gefunden habe, der mir gefiel, ihn noch mal geschaut habe, er weg war. So ein Tag danach. Aber es ist vielleicht, wie gesagt, dass man sich dann, dass es einem besonders auffällt dann, aber das hatte ich bestimmt drei, vier Mal innerhalb irgendwie einer Woche oder so, wo ich dann dachte, okay, jetzt bin ich halt im Fadenkreuz. Also jetzt muss ich auch aufpassen, was ich eingebe, weil alles, was ich jetzt gucke, wird gesperrt, weil das illegal ist und so. Jetzt sind sie in mir drin. Das habe ich auch schon mal gedacht und das ist wahrscheinlich auch, was du dann denkst, wenn die Seiten, die du neu entdeckst, dann immer sofort verschwinden. Aber ich glaube, es ist einfach einfach ein ongoing Kampf zwischen YouTube und den Leuten, die die Videos klauen wollen. Vor allem, man muss ja, also wenn wir jetzt mal davon ausgehen, dass so der Traffic auf so einer Website nach so einer Art Normalverteilung aussieht, also eine Glockenkurve, dann ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit ja sehr hoch, dass du mitten in dieser Glockenkurve drin ist und in dem Moment, in dem du diese Website besuchst, ganz viele andere auch. Also du bist nicht Erste, der diese Webseite findest, du bist auch nicht der Letzte, du bist halt in der Masse. Wobei du schon so versiert bist, weil du ja auch ein Grabber bist der ersten Stunde, wahrscheinlich bist du am Anfang dieser Glockenkurve zu finden. Kann schon auch sein. Deswegen habe ich immer so ein paar Wochen, ein paar Monate Zeit, um möglichst viel runterzuladen, um dann wieder wegzuladen. Aber das ist tatsächlich schwierig, weil ich dadurch, dass ich YouTube-Videos nur im gedownloadeten Zustand schaue, nie die YouTuber unterstütze, die ich schaue. Ich gebe denen keinen Klick in der Regel, weil du kannst immer Rechtsklick Adresse kopieren. Das heißt, ich muss dieses Video gar nicht aufrufen. Ja, aber jetzt müssen diese Seiten ja darauf zugreifen. Das ist ja auch so, wir wissen ja nie, wie viele Hörer wir haben so genau, weil wir nicht wissen, wie oft jetzt noch dann Soundcloud und diese ganzen B-Seiten oder hier Podigy oder wie die ganzen Podcast-Apps alle heißen, ob die sich einmal das grabben vom RSS-Feed und dann halt an die Hörer der App weiter verteilen oder ob es jedes Mal wieder auf den RSS-Feed zugreift. Das heißt, wenn wir die Zugriffe unseres RSS-Feed sehen, wissen wir bis heute nicht genau, wie viele Hörer wir haben. Wahrscheinlich ist es aber bei denen genauso, dass sie ja auch noch auf diese Seite zugreifen müssen. Finde ich spannend. Da müssen wir mal nochmal Schmieder in den Ring holen, dass der vielleicht aufklären kann, ob das als Klick verbucht wird, weil tatsächlich, und das ist ja auch bei zum Beispiel Rocket Beans,
kriegen wir oft den Kommentar, weil die Sendung läuft live auf Twitch und YouTube und dann wird sie nochmal auf YouTube hochgeladen. Und viele Leute, die die Sendung schon live gesehen haben, klicken dann nochmal das YouTube-VoD-Video an, nur um einen Daumen nach oben zu gehen und einen Kommentar zu schreiben. Im Sinne von coole Sendung, ich bin nur hier.
Richtig, das macht das total kaputt, weil so wichtig die Klicks zwar auch sind, wichtiger ist vielleicht noch die Retention-Rate, wie viele Leute sich wie viel Prozent des Videos angeguckt haben, weil was YouTube will, ist, dass Leute ganz lange auf YouTube bleiben, und wenn du die eine Stunde lang mit deinem Video auf YouTube hältst, auf deren Plattform, dann ist das ein wichtiges Video für YouTube und dann wird es hoch und höher gewertet.
Ich mag die Retention-Rate sehr gerne, weil bei unserem Sketch-Channel damals, unserem Comedy-Channel Gute Arbeit Originals, war das immer das Einzige, was das ZDF positiv hervorgehoben hat, weil die Retention immer so toll war, weil alle das Video zu Ende geguckt haben, aber alles andere war halt katastrophal. Aber das war immer toll.
Das heisst, man könnte sogar sagen, das Schlechteste, was man für einen YouTuber machen kann, ist, das Video aufzumachen und sofort wieder zu schliessen. Das ist schlechter, als wenn du es gar nicht angeklickt hättest. Und deswegen, falls ihr Leuten schaden wollt, macht das, weil das ist das Schlimmste, was passieren kann, weil YouTube dann denkt, oh, das ist Clickbait oder das ist einfach ein schlechtes Video und deswegen müssen wir fast schon so eine Aktion starten, um Leuten zu sagen, super nett von euch, wir wissen, dass ihr uns einfach einen Daumen geben wollt und einen Kommentar und das ist ja auch wichtig, aber lasst es dann doch einfach mal im Hintergrund weiterlaufen, das Video. Es ist schwierig, weil es ist eigentlich, mit dem Willen, was Gutes zu tun, tun diese Leute, was maximal schlechtes. Ruinieren den Kanal, kann man ja so deutlich auch mal formulieren. Ja, absolut. Aber er hat jetzt YouTube pp. Hat es nicht, übrigens wird es weitergeleitet, du kommst auf YouTube zwei mate, j y zwei mate, naja, da ist wieder was anderes in der Mache, aber angenommen diese Seite heisst YouTube pp.com und dann macht man danach Slash und dann die URL von YouTube. Haben die dann einfach, und es dann funktioniert, haben die einfach ganz YouTube kopiert und nochmal unter der URL youtubepp.com hochgeladen? Du, das ist eine Frage für Schmieder, aber ich glaube, es ist nicht so trivial, den gesamten YouTube-Content irgendwo hochzuladen. Holy Shit, wo liegen Stunden pro Sekunde hochgeladen werden. Wenn ich angucke, meine Festplatte ist voll, meine Terabyte-Festplatte ist voll. Frag mich nicht warum. Ich habe ein paar Mal meinen MacBook gebackupt, die ist jetzt voll. Und die ist relativ gross. Und die hat einen Terabyte. Das ist jetzt auch nicht so wahnsinnig viel. Und jetzt überleg mal, wie viele Daten im Internet sind. Wo liegen diese ganzen Daten? In irgendwelchen riesen Serverfarmen wahrscheinlich, irgendwo in der Arktis oder in Grönland. Sagt man noch, auf Grönland ist es, wie groß muss eine Insel sein, bis man innen sagt? Ich weiß es nicht. Ich glaube nicht. Ich glaube, du kannst ja einfach, wenn du den Teil aus der URL dann kopieren und dann einfach das YouTube-Video aufrufen und einbetten oder so. Ich weiss es nicht. Aber wie gesagt, das sind alles Schmiedenfragen. Also sobald wir ihn haben, sobald wir ihn erreicht haben, können wir ihn das alles mal fragen, wie das aussieht. Aber ich habe noch einen ganzen Stock an runtergeladenen Videos, aber manchmal werden die halt auch falsch runtergeladen, was super nervig ist und hören dann mittendrin auf oder werden asynchron oder sind dann irgendwie plötzlich schlechte, schlechte Qualität.
Das ist einfach, das ist einfach ein System, das nicht funktioniert. Oder das ist ein anderes Video. Das ist furchtbar. Aber das ist ja wiederum spannend. Dann hast du vielleicht mal irgendwie so ein Random, wie so dieses Multiversum-TV bei Rick and Morty. Guckst du mal kurz in so eine ganz andere Seite ein. Vor allem, ich bin es jetzt einfach leid, weisst du, wir haben vor zehn Jahren eine Special-Sendung zu Machine Learning, künstlicher Intelligenz und so gemacht. Und wo ist es? Wo ist es? Weißt du, was ich will? Ich will, angenommen, ich surfe im Internet. Und dann möchte ich einfach den Internetstecker ziehen können und dann noch den Rest des Tages weiter surfen können, weil mein Computer mich so gut kennt, dass er genau weiss, welche Videos ich als nächstes alles aufrufen werde, die alles schon mal präventiv runterlädt, so dass ich eigentlich gar kein aktives Internet mehr brauche, weil er genau schon weiss, auf welche Seiten ich gehe, welche Videos ich aufrufe, was ich mache und das alles schon vorbereitet hat sozusagen und ich aber das gar nicht merke, weil der klüger ist als ich, so das will ich, ich will einfach sagen, oh mein Zug fährt in zehn Minuten, jetzt klinke ich mich aus und dann kann ich im Zug noch weiter surfen, einfach weil der schon die nächsten Stunden vorausgeplant hat. Ja, das finde ich super. Wo ist diese Technologie, Stefan, wo ist es denn? Ich bin doch genau, da hat zu oft das... Ja, Schmiede, Schmiede hat es in der Schublade und holt es nicht raus! Weil er als erstes einen Maisbietenden verscherbeln will. Ja, komm. Ja, das ist doch genau das. Wächerlich. Ich habe neulich mal gedacht, stimmt, wir haben ja auch mal über damals, hast du mal gesagt, oh, bald kommt dieses Amazon Alexa raus. Oh Gott, jetzt ist sie angegangen. Oh Gott. Alle Fenster gehen auf, Waschbecken füllt sich, nein! Und dann hast du gesagt, glaube ich damals im Podcast, so was wie, ja, und das ist dann unser dritter Host, mit dem können wir dann immer sprechen. Und es fühlt sich langsam an, wenn man heutzutage so 80er Jahre Dokumentation aus dem ZDF sieht, wie sie über das Internet sprechen und so und von dem Teufelszeug oder oh, Menschen können nicht mit Zügen fahren, weil dann wird das Gehirn weggefräst, weil man so schnell nicht fahren darf.
So, genau so hören wir uns an vor drei Jahren, wie wir über Alexa sprechen.
Oh Gott!
Aber auf der anderen Seite ist es einfach immer noch, hat sich da nicht viel getan.
Es ist nach wie vor diese schlechte Sprachsteuerung, die wir von damals hatten, nur halt mit ein bisschen mehr Backend. Aber es ist ja nicht so, dass man sich wahnsinnig cool mit unterhalten kann und sieht jetzt irgendwie ein dritter Host, wer hier Gags macht und sowas. Das finde ich so schade. Da ist noch so viel Potenzial. Ja, es ist schade. Ich glaube, solange Schmiede da nicht selber Hand anlegt, wird das auch nichts. Wobei ich mal die Frage stellen möchte, ob Schmieder denn der Beste ist. Weil Crip-Grab wurde ja auch jetzt gegrabt. Aber das ist so verrückt, die Vorstellung, dass das Internet, was jeder Mensch der Welt benutzt, eigentlich von wahrscheinlich einer Handvoll Leuten gebaut wurde. Also jetzt natürlich über die lange Jahre und so, aber gerade so Plattformen wie ClipGrab, die ich jedes Mal benutze. Und ich denke mir, das ist eine einzige Person, die das gebaut hat. Hätte die das nicht gemacht, klar kann man immer sagen, hätte es jemand anders gemacht oder so, aber im Endeffekt sind es einfach einzelne Personen, die dann sowas machen oder auch so einen YouTube-Kanal, der Alte, zum Beispiel das Literarische Quartett schaue ich mir immer ganz gerne an, lade es mir auch runter und da gibt es einen, der hat alle Folgen hochgeladen.
Und ich mir denke, wenn es diese Person einfach nicht gäbe, gäbe es die einfach nicht auf YouTube, gäbe es die einfach nicht im Internet nicht. Es gibt nur eine einzige Person braucht es und jedes von diesen Videos hat hunderttausend Klicks minimum und aber alles nur wegen einer Person. Es sind einfach eine Handvoll Leute, die dafür sorgen, dass alle eine gute Zeit haben. Wenn jeder sich so anstrengen würde. Ich mache das immer bei der bei Harald Schmidt Show, die gucke ich mir immer noch gerne an, wo alle Folgen auf YouTube sind von einer Person hochgeladen und auch alle haben sehr viele Klicks. Da denke ich mir auch immer, Gott sei Dank sind das aber auch Menschen, die glaube ich mittlerweile den Zugang vergessen haben oder sowas oder noch nicht wissen, was sie da gemacht haben, weil die haben ja so viele Klicks, die könnten ja easy zu den erfolgreichen Channels der Welt gehören und müssten ja einfach nur ein bisschen Werbung schalten und könnten sie so fast ihr Leben finanzieren, die haben im Schnitt so viele Videos wie Rocket Beans quasi hochgeladen, aber haben halt keine Werbung davor geschaltet, weil sie vielleicht ihr Passwort, also wahrscheinlich, vielleicht ist einer von euch, hat so einen Onkel, der alle Folgen, ups, die Panne Show hochgeladen hat bei YouTube, der aber das Passwort vergessen hat oder sowas und jetzt nicht die Werbung schalten kann. Wie schade. Ja, das sind die wahren Helden des Internets, die mal einen Nachmittag abgeloadet haben und dann irgendwie ihr Passwort vergessen haben.
Ich sag mal, also ich weiss nicht, ob das, na, ich weiss nicht, ob es illegal ist, aber ich habe... Das sind die wahren Helden des Internets, die mal einen Nachmittag upgeloadet haben und dann irgendwie ihr Passwort vergessen haben.
Ich sag mal, also ich weiß nicht, ob das, na, ich weiß nicht, ob es illegal ist, aber ich habe versucht, das jetzt mal so vage zu formulieren wie möglich. Ich habe auch schon mal was hochgeladen auf YouTube. Das noch ist unverfänglich. Was hast du denn hochgeladen? Sagen wir mal Folgendes, ich habe eine Box mit Datenträgern erworben und habe dann davon nicht den Hauptteil dieser Datenträger hochgeladen, sondern das, was noch zusätzlich dabei ist, habe ich hochgeladen. Und da war es interessant, weil dann habe ich so einen Kanal zum Hochladen, den wir niemand finden, aber das ist auch interessant, weil dann konnte ich da wirklich 20 Filme hochladen und dann hatte ich noch eine andere DVD gefunden, äh, Datenträger gefunden. Du hast auch gerade Filme hochladen gesagt. Du bist auf jeden Fall hinter den Netz. Von 1993 oder so und habe versucht, die hochzuladen. Und wirklich, der Download-Balken war noch nicht mal bei ein Prozent angekommen. Und es kam sofort eine Fehlermeldung. Was die hochladen, ist Copyright richtig geschützt, dürfen sie auf gar keinen Fall machen. Die Hunde ist abgebrochen. Also die checken das sofort, aber bei allem anderen nicht. Also du kannst echt einfach so Try-and-Error-mäßig versuchen, alles hochzzuladen und alles, was durchgeht, ja, keine Ahnung, ob mir der Account gehört, ich habe da kein Passwort nicht und mein, ich gebe da so einen jungen Nachhilfe, der ist auch manchmal am Rechner, vielleicht hat der das hochgeladen, keine Ahnung, ich kriege ja niemand so, das kann dir ja niemand nachweisen. Ich habe damals auf Clipfish viel gemacht. Ich habe mich schon alle Ausreden vorüberlegt, falls du es gemerkt hast. Ich hab das damals auf Clipfish auch gemacht. Ich hab einfach eine Fortwerbung runtergeladen
und wieder hochgeladen, weil ich die lustig fand damals.
Hat die nicht sogar jemand
gefunden aus der Community? Das kann gut sein, ehrlich gesagt.
So eine Fortwerbung mit so einem schlechten
Vogelwitz.
Und die ist jetzt, hab ich noch hochgeladen,
weil ich die Clips
weggraben wollte, die Clicks
und hat auch ein bisschen funktioniert. Ich hatte, glaube ich, einen Kommentar, so einen Daumen nach oben, Lach-Emoji und zwei Klicks und so, war damit sehr glücklich, oder 21 war damit sehr glücklich. Aber das finde ich sehr spannend. Ich finde aber auch, diesen Podcast hier ist rechtlich sehr spannend, weil wir, ich habe ja vor ein paar Wochen mal erzählt, dass ein Kumpel von mir ein Bild geklaut hat. Und im Nebensatz habe ich wohl aus Versehen erwähnt, dass es in Berlin war. Hier wäre jetzt eine grosse Sache draus gemacht, dass ich das nicht verraten kann und so. Im Nebensatz, wie du gerade auch, einfach alles verraten. Aber jetzt frage ich mich, weil wir sind ja ein Comedy-Podcast, können wir uns nicht immer aufs Comedy-Gesetz beziehen und immer sagen, es war ein Scherz?
Ich glaube schon, was damals im 12. Jahrhundert unter Papst Hilarius beschlossen wurde, dass Comedy per se halt einfach ein bisschen Baller-Baller ist und nicht so ernst. Papst Hilarius! Es gibt Papst Hilarius! Und guckt euch mal seinen Wappen an, er hat eine rote Nase, nein, aber leider nicht, aber es gab Papst Hilarius und guckt euch mal seinen Wappen an. Er hat eine rote Nase. Nein, aber leider nicht. Aber es gab Papst Hilarius. Und ehrlich gesagt, wenn ich jemals zum Papst, ist es ja unwahrscheinlich, ich bin jetzt auch aus der Kirche ausgereden, aber wenn ich nochmal zum Papst gebeten werden sollte, was ja immer noch mein Ziel ist, dann glaube ich, würde ich mich Papst Hilarius der Zweite nennen, ehrlich gesagt. Ja, absolut. Von fantastischen Namen.
Kriegt man, wenn man Papst wird, eigentlich so eine Liste an Namen vorgesetzt, oder kann man sich auch Papst Bobo nennen oder einfach sich was Eigenes ausgeben? Papst Stephan. Hilarius war Erzdiakon unter Papst Leo dem Ersten und nahm Leo und nahm in dessen Auftrag 449 am Konzil von Ephesos teil. Hier wurde unter Anwendung von Gewalt der Monophysit Eutyches, der nur die göttliche, nicht aber die menschliche Natur Jesu behauptete, für rechtgläubig erklärt. Hilarius, der hat sich kaputt gelacht darüber, der deutlich den Kirchenbann gegen Flavianus von Konstantinopel bekämpfte, musste fliehen. Das Konzil von Chalkedon verwarf das, auch Gott, ich kenne kein Wort, ich habe bis jetzt nichts verstanden. Nach dem Einfall der Vandalen in Rom 455 verschenkte Hilarius einen Grossleiter seines Besitzers an Comedy-Clubs. Die Sade Hilarius wurde nach dem Tod Leos wahrscheinlich am 17. November 461 zum Papst gewählt und am 19. November geweiht. Er starb am 28. Februar in Klammern Fragezeichen. Das ist bald! 28. Februar nach einer abweichenden Auffassung dauerte sein Pontifikat vom 13. November 1461 bis zum 19. Februar 1468. Sein Name bedeutet der Heitere. Ja. Oh, ey, wir müssen eigentlich, es ist ja bald 28. Februar, da müssen wir eigentlich den Todestag von Papst Hedarius feiern. Genau. Zumindest einen Tweet raushauen, ich glaube, das hätte er so gewollt. Sein Gedenktag der katholischen Kirche ist der 29. Februar allerdings, einen Tag später. Ist das nicht der Tag, den es so einmal in vier Jahren gibt? Weil die finden, für die Kirche ist Spaß okay, aber nur alle vier Jahre kann man dem gedenken. Und auch warum einen Tag nach dem Tod. Naja, viele Fragen. Äh, warte mal, das stimmt. Schalt ja, dann hat der Februar 29 statt 28 Tage. Ja, wir haben dieses Jahr einen Tag mehr. Aber ganz kurz, der Gedenktag ist wirklich der 29. Februar? Ja, obwohl er am 28. gestorben war. What? In kleinen Fragezeichen? Das kann doch kein Zufall sein. Nee, die wollen, ja wie gesagt, Kirche ist ja für Spaß zu haben, aber eben nur alle vier Jahre. Papst Hilarius war ja auch ein Querdenker. Der war ein Querdenker, der war Angie. Wann ist er gestorben? Weil das Schaltjahr wurde erst 1582 eingeführt, wie es mir scheint. Am 28. Februar 468. Also gut tausend Jahre davor.
Alter, alt.
Papst Hilarius. Wahnsinn.
Das finde ich wahnsinnig spannend.
Aber vielleicht haben die das absichtlich auf den Tag gelegt.
Ich meine, ich kann es nicht die ganzen Artikel durchlesen, aber es gibt bestimmt einen Grund, warum man genau den 29. Februar gewählt hat.
Vielleicht wegen Papst Hilarius, das kann schon sein.
Ja, weil es auch irgendwie lustig ist, alle vier Jahre nur einen Tag. Ist lustig, gleiche ich mich kaputt, gleiche ich mir ins Fäustchen. Paps Hilarius. Kleiner Service hier, Podcast UFO Service, Schaltjahr 2020, gibt es wieder ein Schaltjahr. Ja, das ist, ja, jetzt. Also wir können tatsächlich den 29. feiern dieses Jahr. Sehr gut, sehr, sehr gut. Aber verrückte Geschichte, da müsste man auch einfach eine Doku über Hilarius machen.
Papst Hilarius, der Scherzkeks.
Ich finde es wahrscheinlich fast nichts mehr.
Allein die Tatsache, dass wir überhaupt wissen, was passiert ist vor 1500 Jahren, ist schon echt erstaunlich.
Naja, aber wissen wir so viel?
Ich habe immer das Gefühl, ja, weil so Kirchen, also so Kirchenkram ist relativ gut dokumentiert,
diese ganze Papstwahlgeschichte und so, weil die ja auch sich nicht verändert hat, glaube ich, und immer schon sehr viele Leute darauf bedacht waren, das gut zu archivieren. Weiss man darüber viel, aber darüber hinaus, was war in den Jahren 468 noch? Wahrscheinlich nichts. Der Wikipedia-Artikel ist auch ganz, ganz kurz nur. Der Vandalenfeldzug des West- und Oströmischen Reiches unter Leistung Kaisalios scheitert kläglich, nicht zuletzt an den Rivalitäten zwischen den West- und Oströmischen Kommandeuren Rieszima und Basiliskos.
Das ist schon verrückt. Ich hoffe ja, dass es ein gutes Online-Archiv geben wird, dass es nicht irgendwann gelöscht wird, dass man das alles, aber es ist ja eigentlich auch eine Möglichkeit, Geschichte zu verhindern, indem man einfach zu viel speichert. Weil ich glaube, jetzt so gerade so altes Ägypten oder so, da hast du dann zwei Steintafeln und denkst dir halt den Rest aus so ein bisschen oder überlegst, ja, keine Ahnung, die haben vielleicht den Nil irgendwie, da hat wahrscheinlich eine Rolle gespielt, aber die Probleme der zukünftigen Historiker wird wahrscheinlich sein, dass es einfach zu viele Informationen gibt und man dann auch wieder nicht weiss, was los war. Das kann sein, das kann sein. Papst Hilarius und danach kam Papst Simplicius. Also erst hat man gelacht und dann dachte man, jetzt kommen wir wieder back to the basics. Und danach kam Felix der Zweite, der Glückliche. Es war aber Hilarius der Erste, oder? Also er hat sich diesen Namen das erste Mal gegeben. Also kann man sich neue Namen geben, kannst du dich auch Papst Batman nennen. Ja, aber Franziskus ist ja auch der Zweite. Der Erste, pardon. Ja, Papst Franziskus ist auch der Erste. Das finde ich auch so clever. Benedikt der Sechzehnte, hallo? Das ist ja auch irgendwie dann langweilig. Vor allem, dann muss es ja auch mal einen Dreizehnten gegeben haben, ne? Das ist ja schon eigentlich badass. Hier, der Papst von The Young Pope mit Jude Law ist ja auch der Dreizehnte. Ich glaube, Pius der Dreizehnte, ja. Fantastische Serie übrigens, gerne mal angucken. Es kommt jetzt auch bald ein Film dazu raus mit John Malkovich. Ah, das ist ein Film. Alles toll. Ich habe da ja so ein bisschen so eine Faszination, aber auch nur für das Ästhetische, das ganze sexinische Kapelle und Riesi und diese Gewänder und so. Und inhaltlich interessiert mich das nicht so, aber ich finde das schon cool. Und Young Pope hat mich auch echt fasziniert, habe ich mir zweimal angeschaut die Serie, weil das schon irgendwie einen Reiz hat. Young Pope ist wirklich fantastisch. Ich mag das total gern. Also ich finde die Prämisse auch einfach toll, dass einfach ein sehr, sehr junger Papst gewählt wird. Aus Amerika auch geil, eine Vorstellung, dass ein englischsprachiger Papst, weil das für mich hat Englisch immer nicht so viel mit dem Christentum zu tun, weiß ich auch nicht, ist auch eine blöde Fausalität, aber irgendwie verbindet man diese Sprache nicht so richtig mit diesem altertümlichen Latein, finde ich immer, und das ist geil und dann, dass er einfach so wahnsinnig radikal ist, ist einfach eine super spannende Prämisse. Man, vor allem, ich dachte mir, oh, Serie über einen jungen Papst und dann denkt man erst mal, ah okay, der ist jetzt total liberal, der öffnet das alles irgendwie, Schwule sind okay, alles in Ordnung.
So fängt das ja auch an die Serie.
So genau fängt er es ja auch an. Ja, und dann denkt man sich, oh, wie toll wäre es denn, so einen Papst zu haben.
Aber cool finde ich, dass die Serie das genaue Gegenteil macht und den Papst als den absolut konservativsten, radikalsten, zurück zur Tradition macht.
Und das, also irgendwie kann man das so ein bisschen mitfühlen irgendwie. Also er ist natürlich nicht der Bösewicht und man denkt sich, was für ein Arschloch, aber einfach weil er so cool ist und das alles macht, funktioniert das auch total gut. Also Serienempfehlung The Young Pope auf jeden Fall. The Young Pope ist fantastisch, ja. Ich glaube, es ist die zweite Staffel, aber bin mir auch immer noch nicht sicher. Ich will jetzt auch nicht lange googeln.
Ja, das findet ihr auch schon selber heraus. Wir müssen euch ja nicht alles sagen. Wir sind ja, wir sind da für 1500 Jahre alte Informationen, nicht für aktuelle, sondern dafür sind wir hier. Ja genau, bei uns könnt ihr nichts über die Thüringen-Wahl hören, bei uns hört ihr über die Wahl von Papst Hilarius im Jahre 445. So das ist doch unser und deswegen solltet ihr uns auch für den Deutschen Podcastpreis wählen, weil alles andere gibt es ja zuhauf. Ich wollte noch einmal sagen, weil die Wahl ist bald vorbei, Ende Februar ist sie vorbei. Wir freuen uns natürlich über eure Stimme. Ihr könnt abstimmen auf deutscherpodcastpreis.de aber auch für andere tolle Podcasts. Es gibt ja auch noch andere tolle Podcasts. Ja, und vor allem, wenn ihr für das Podcast-Ufo abstimmt, stimmt ihr ja nicht nur für uns beide ab, sondern vor allem für Thais, die wir wieder auf die Preisverlagung schicken werden. Die hat sich extra ein schönes Kleid gekauft, die kommt mal raus, die hat mal irgendwie so einen schönen Glamour-Abend. Tut ihr doch einfach den Gefallen, damit sie einen schönen Abend hat, dass ihr uns den Podcast-Preis gegeben habt. Ich weiß gar nicht, warum du sie jetzt so darstellst, dass so immer drinnen wäre und hat da jemanden schönen Glamour-Abend. Ich glaube, die macht die schönere Abende als wir, um ehrlich zu sein. Ja, absolut. Deswegen schicken wir die auch da hin. Ja, klar. Nee, das stimmt. Dann macht Taisa eine grosse Freude. Gefällt mir auch gut dieser Zwang, den du jetzt auf ihre Schultern setzt. Aber die sind ja bestimmt Lust drauf. Klar. Ja, genau. Ach, ich bin ja mittlerweile ein großer Köln-Fan, muss ich sagen. Ich habe mich ein bisschen an die Stadt gewöhnt. Ich weiß nicht, wie es dir geht hier. Aber mittlerweile finde ich Köln fantastisch, habe mich auch sehr an die Stadt gewöhnt, auch daran, dass ich wirklich die schönste Stadt ist, aber die Menschen sind so herzlich, bla bla bla. Aber es stellt sich hier neulich raus, dass die Stadt vielleicht gar nicht so nett ist, wie ich mittlerweile denke. Denn was? Ich habe mittlerweile ja einen guten Freund, einen Autorenkollegen aus der Schweiz und der hat jetzt dann mal seine Schweizer Freunde eingeladen, aus Zürich, aus dem schönen Zürich, sie hergeholt, um denen immer Köln zu zeigen und man muss sich das vorstellen, so, dann gingen halt diese drei Schweizer Jungs, diese reinen Schweizer Seelen, die niemandem etwas zu leide tun würden, auch weil sie einfach keiner Partei angehören wollen und sehr neutral sind und unbefleckt, sauber mit ihren schönen Markenklamotten ständen durch die Stadt und wollten dann abends noch was trinken gehen. Und die Freunde sind gerade angekommen, gehen ein paar Meter durch die Stadt und sind ganz aufgeregt, gucken sich mit grossen Augen um, da spuckt ihnen ein Obdachloser ins Gesicht. Willkommen in Köln! Viva Gloria! Wir lieben das... Und es ist wirklich einfach eine fantastische... Das war schon die ganze Geschichte. Aber holy shit, da hat ein Obdachlose, hat sich vor die hingestellt und die mitten ins Gesicht gespuckt. What? Wow! Meine erste Frage war, habt ihr dem irgendwas gesagt, habt ihr den beschimpft oder so? Ja, wir in Deutschland haben Obdachlose, kein Grund, die beschimpfen zu müssen. Aber nein, es war einfach nur, der hat sich vor die gestellt und hat die angespuckt. Und danach sind sie danach in eine Bar gegangen und da war so ein Türsteher und dann waren die noch alle ganz aufgeregt und haben gesagt, da vorne hat uns Obdachlose bespuckt und dann kam hinter denen einer an, also der nach, der in die Bar gehen wollte, hat auch gesagt, ich wurde auch bespuckt, ich wurde auch bespuckt und dann dachten die schon irgendwie, das wäre normal und in Köln wird jeder bespuckt, erstmal von Obdachlosen und die gesamte Bar dreht sich auch um und so, ja, ich auch, ja, wir auch und dann hat der Tischtehr wohl gesagt, ja, das ist normal, der hat da schon ein paar bespuckt heute, da sitzt halt jemand, der bespuckt Leute, das ist nicht so schön, aber fand ich einen ganz netten Gruß. Das ist schwierig. Ja, aber es ist glaube ich dann noch nicht so einfach als Schweizer, sich an Köln zu gewöhnen, wo ja alles da sehr schön ist und sehr rein ist und sehr sauber ist. Naja. Traurig. Nee, ich würde auch nie, also ich habe ja schon Probleme, Leuten Dinge schmackhaft zu machen, die ich gut finde, aber wenn Leute so mich besuchen würden in Köln und so, zeig uns mal die Stadt, ich glaube, das wäre so unangenehm für mich, weil ich nicht wüsste, was man denen jetzt zeigt, was die beeindruckt oder was das macht, weil ich habe gar keine Ahnung. Ich denke mir auch immer so, wenn berühmte Leute, so wenn man hört so, oh, Beyonce ist jetzt in Berlin oder so und dann denkt man sich auch immer so, ah, ich hoffe, sie mag die Stadt, aber was, was, also vielleicht, ich meine, der Fernsehturm, was, also oft ist ja eine Stadt nicht so an einzelnen Dingen, sondern es ist so ein Lebensgefühl, was natürlich schwer ist für jemanden als Büro zu vermitteln.
zu vermitteln, weil die ja auch wahrscheinlich das Lebensgefühl gar nicht... Total. Die kennt man ja auch hier.
Das ist schon krass. Ja, aber ich verstehe Obdachlose
nicht so ganz, weil ich war auch
tatsächlich neulich mal auf dem
Stadt unterwegs und dann kam ein
Obdachloser auf mich zu,
was ich aber erst nicht verstanden habe, weil der hat eine sehr, sehr, so eine ganz tolle Lederjacke an. Ich dachte, der will mich einfach jetzt auf dem Weg fragen, aber es war jemand, der nach Geld fragen wollte. Und dann ist mir das Paradoxon erstmal klar geworden, klar, Obdachlose wollen Geld, um sich Wärme anzuziehen oder sich schönere Sachen zu kaufen, die nicht dann mehr stinken, oder die wollen dann auch, klar, kaufen damit dann auch was zu essen oder halt auch Alkohol, aber da hat jemand, war so gut im Obdachlossein, dass er sich eine sehr gute Lederjacke kaufen konnte, was mich aber dazu bringt, mit meinem blöden Stammhirn, dem jetzt kein Geld zu geben, weil ich denke, dem geht es ja gut. Deshalb als Obdachloser soll es nicht in deinem Interesse sein, bessere Klamotten zu bekommen. Das macht dich kaputt als Obdachloser. Das ist total paradox, aber du musst eigentlich als Obdachloser versuchen, wärmere Klamotten zu bekommen oder keine Ahnung, aber die dürfen nicht schön sein weil wenn du schön Klamotten hast, kriegst du kein Geld mehr. Und ich glaube auch, dass ich eher Geld bekomme als ein Obdachloser wiederum auf der anderen Seite, weil wenn ich ja ja ja das habe ich auch schon mal gesagt ja das ist so wenn ich irgendwo stehe und sage jetzt oh Gott jetzt bitte noch 20 Cent für diese Limo kriege ich sofort Geld. Und vor allem ein Effekt, der mir auch aufgefallen ist, weil ich hatte mal vor einiger Zeit einen Zusammenstoss mit einem Trickbetrüger am Kölner Hauptbahnhof. Und das habe ich erst später gecheckt, dass das ein Trickbetrüger war, wie das so oft war. Nee, das war einer, der so meinte, ja, er muss jetzt in eine andere Stadt fahren, weil da hat er irgendwie einen Termin beim Arbeitsamt oder so und er kriegt heute jetzt einen Job und so. Und er muss jetzt halt nur dahin und er hat halt kein Geld. Und dann hat er gesagt, ich brauche 20 Euro, um da hinzukommen. Und das war dann auch so ein interessanter Moment, weil ich denke mir, dass ich jemandem eher 20 Euro geben würde als ein Euro, weil ein Euro, das ist so, ja, der fragt ganz viele und der bettelt halt den ganzen Tag und so. Aber wenn du sagst, so 20 Euro, dann ist es so ein, okay, ich helfe dir jetzt auf einem anderen Niveau, so, ich helfe dir irgendwie so. Verstehst du, was ich meine, Grob? Ja, ja, auf jeden Fall. Das ist was anderes dann und man begegnet den mehr eher auf Augenhöhe, so blöd das klingt. Genau, ja, genau. Aber das ist so, man meint, es ist relatable, diese Situation und man will auch, dass einem geholfen wird. Aber ich finde Trickbetrüger in der Hinsicht dann so ein bisschen redundant.
Ich verstehe den Ausdruck auch nicht. Man hat eher so das Gefühl, ich könnte auch in so einer Situation sein, dass ich halt mal irgendwo gestrandet bin und ich habe halt meinen Kreditkarten, ich habe kein Geld dabei und ich brauche jetzt halt einfach irgendwie keine 20 Euro für ein Taxi und dann denkt man sich eher, weil es ist alles falsch, was man denkt und natürlich sollte man einem Geld geben oder auch nicht oder was auch immer, keine Ahnung, schwer zu sagen, aber das halte zu hoch. Ja, aber das ist mir erst später aufgefallen, weil der wollte dann eben das Geld und der stand dann eben mit mir vor dem Automaten und dann habe ich ihm das Geld gegeben, aber ich glaube dann irgendwann meinte er noch so, nee, er braucht für seine Frau auch noch Geld, ich habe es nicht mehr hundertprozentig, ich habe es in den Moin Moin erzählt. Aber das ist die nächste Stufe, weil das muss nämlich der Lederjacken tragende Obdachlose jetzt auch machen, weil seine Jacke ist zu schön, um jetzt noch nach einem Euro zu fragen. Er müsste jetzt dann das an, deswegen verstehe ich dann solche Leute auch wiederum, aber warum heißt es Trickbetrüger? Es klingt auf eine Art gefährlich und cool, aber es ist auch irgendwie, ich verstehe das Wort nicht, weil es ist ja redundant. Es kommt gerade wieder so ein bisschen zurück. Ich glaube, die Sache war, ich stand mit ihm am Automaten und wollte dann für ihn die Karte kaufen. Also ich wollte den Zwanziger in den Automaten tun und davon hat er mich abgehalten. Er hat gesagt so, nee, nee, nee. Und da hätte ich eigentlich schon merken müssen, der will kein Ticket, der will einfach nur das Geld, und das wäre wahrscheinlich auch die richtige Möglichkeit gewesen, darauf zu beharren, dass man ihm jetzt das Ticket hier und jetzt kauft. Egal, war total dumm, und ich habe danach auch Nachrichten bekommen, dass schon andere darauf reingefallen sind, und ich glaube, das ist so der Effekt, man fällt da einmal drauf rein, und dann hoffentlich hat man es gecheckt, aber deswegen, ja, muss man einfach nicht dumm sein, das ist der Rat, den ich jedem gebe. Na gut, dann haben wir auch noch was zu mitnehmen heute. Das finde ich auch ganz gut. Deutsche Pokraspreis, können wir mal abstimmen. Ja, ich habe gerade was, ich kriege sehr viele Mails, sorry, wenn ich ab und zu ein bisschen abgelenkt bin, aber ich kriege sehr viele Mails, gerade weil ich meinen Fernseher reingestellt habe bei Ebay. Es war letzte Woche, war ich noch sehr euphorisiert, wie ihr euch vielleicht erinnert. Mittlerweile bin ich... Ja, Cash-Stefan, hast du schon wieder zugeschaltet. Cash-Stefan hat ein bisschen mehr Geld gemacht jetzt, aber Cash-Stefan will auch kein Geld machen, Cash-Stefan will einfach nur seine Sachen loswerden. Aber jetzt habe ich meinen Fernseher reingestellt, habe leider vergessen, einen Preis reinzustellen, deswegen kamen gerade sehr, sehr viele Nachrichten. Und meine Händenummer war da auch
und da wurde ganz oft angerufen gerade.
Aber das ist auch nervig.
Man sollte es nicht.
Apropos Mails, wir hatten es ja letztens mal
damit, wie kann man Leuten sagen,
dass man das ein Kompliment machen oder wie kann
man generell über Dinge reden, über die man sonst nicht redet.
Und ein Anliegen,
wir reden über generische Scheisse.
dass ich manchmal habe, ist, dass ich Mails kriege, und ich kriege sehr viel Spam, weil ich bin ein Idiot und ist egal, ich kriege einfach wahnsinnig viel Spam. Und manchmal kriege ich Mails von Leuten und denke, ah, das ist Spam und dann stellt sich später raus, das war kein Spam. Das war eine Podcast-Sofonachricht. Ja, unter anderem. Und dann würde ich gerne den Leuten so das Feedback geben. Hey, du schreibst Mails wie Spam. Sei dir dessen bewusst, dass du wahrscheinlich oft nicht ernst genommen wirst, weil Leute denken, das ist Spam. Gerade wenn man dann so schreibt, sehr geehrter Herr Will, betreffend ihres Anliegens von letzter Woche schicke ich ihnen hier nochmal die Zusammenfassung. Keine persönliche Unterschrift und dann irgendein gezeichnet Prinz Dennis. So denkt man auch Leute. Und dann so eine angehängte Datei, die einen super kruden Namen hat oder einfach nur Abrechnung heißt und ich das einfach nicht aufmache. Und dann müsste man echt so eine Rückmeldung geben, hey, du schreibst wie Spam, sei mir nicht böse, eine Karte, sei mir nicht böse, aber du schreibst wie Spam. Weil ich glaube, die Leute wundern sich, warum nie Leute antworten auf ihre Nachrichten, aber weil es einfach so unpersönlich ist. Ja, zu unpersönlich und in krudem Deutsch, daran erkennt man es auch immer. Ja, das stimmt, und ich bin auch immer bei Anhängen, immer werde ich immer nervös direkt. Aber ich freue mich auch immer bei Anhängen. Bei mir haben auch ...
Ganz kurz um das ... Ja, ja. Nee, bitte. Ich wollte noch ganz kurz einen kurzen Exkurs machen zum Thema Mail, weil natürlich reden wir nicht nur über generische Sachen, sondern auch über sehr alte Sachen, wie anscheinend auch in der letzten Folge wir über Judas geredet haben. und Stefan sich beschwert hat, dass in der Bibel nicht stand, was Judas mit seinem Cash gemacht hat.
Stefan ist jetzt auch gerade zu viel Kleingeld gekommen durch Ebay-Kleinzeigen. Man fragt sich, wohin mit den 30 Silbertagen? Hä? Wohin mit dem Geld? Hä? Naja, Bargeld, sagen wir mal Bargeld. Es gibt zwei Stefans und der eine nimmt ab und zu Personen auf und manchmal ich. What? Nein. Naja, sagen wir mal, du kriegst doch über Ebay-Kleinzeigen Bargeld, oder, aber ich habe nicht über... Wird ja über Judas gesprochen, noch darüber, wo er... ob das nirgendwo... Doch, wir haben in der letzten Folge über Judas gesprochen, Stefan. Und natürlich hat unsere Theologen-Bubble zugeschlagen und hat uns Mails geschrieben, was Judas denn mit seinem Cash, Cash, Cash gemacht hat. Man will sich das ja natürlich auch vergolden lassen oder versilbern lassen, wenn man den Heil Heilern verrät und will sich das natürlich bezahlt machen. Und die Frage ist, was hat Judas mit dem Geld gemacht? Da schreibt uns unser, ja sozusagen unser Podcast-Theologe Jurek schreibt uns aus Norwegen und der hat geschrieben, dass es zwei verschiedene... Sehr nah an Judas angelehnt. Das ist mir gar nicht aufgefallen, aber du hast recht.
Und er schreibt, dass es zwei verschiedene Versionen in der Bibel gab. Zwei verschiedene... Sehr nah an Judas angelehnt. Das ist mir gar nicht aufgefallen, aber du hast recht.
Und er schreibt, dass es zwei verschiedene Versionen in der Bibel gab, was Judas mit dem Geld gemacht hat.
Weil natürlich klar, verschiedene Interviews, Matthäus hat mit ihm gesprochen und Lukas hat mit ihm gesprochen und beiden hat er so unterschiedliche Sachen erzählt, ist ja oft so.
Und Matthäus schreibt, dass Judas das Geld wieder zurückgegeben hat oder dass er es zurückgeben wollte und sich danach erhängt hat, weil er bereut hat, Jesus verraten zu haben. Und er hat das Geld den hohen Priestern wieder zurückgegeben, aber die hohen Priester wollten das Geld nicht für den Tempel benutzen, weil es Blutgeld ist. Was ich nicht ganz verstehe, weil du gehst zu der Polizei und sagst, hey, ich verrate euch Jesus, gebt mir Geld und dann geben die dir Geld, dann verrätst du Jesus und dann kommst du wieder zurück und sagst, ich gebe das Geld wieder zurück und dann sagen die, nee, wir nehmen das Geld nicht an, das ist Blutgeld, aber das Geld kommt ja von euch, ihr seid ja dafür verantwortlich, dass Jesus gestorben ist. Was meinen die denn, wie ihr Tempel gebaut wurde? Es ist auch ein Bluttempel. Ja, also völlig leckerlich. Ja, das ist völlig leckerlich. Was für Hypocrites. Und die hohen Priester haben dann Acker davon gekauft, der dann später Blutacker heisst. Laut Lukas aber ist es eine ganz andere Situation. Ist das ein Fan von uns oder ist das ein Fan oder der Apostel? Ne, der Apostel Lukas sagt, I call Bullshit und hat gesagt, dass Judas das Geld nicht zurückgegeben hat, sich auch nicht erhängt hat. Also zwei stark auseinanderdriftende Versionen, die natürlich die Moral der ganzen Geschichte auch verändern, aber gut, warum nicht? Und Lukas schreibt, dass Judas sich Äcker gekauft hat von dem Geld.
Ah, okay, aber da endet dann die Geschichte gleich.
Und da hat er geschrieben, auf dem Acker ist er dann aber sehr unglücklich hingefallen,
wodurch er in zwei Hälften zerbrach und seine Gedärme sich auf dem Acker verteilt haben. Und deswegen hieß der Acker später Blutacker. Okay. Weil Judas in zwei Teile auseinandergebrochen ist. Zwei unterschiedliche Wege dorthin. Aber okay, also wir wissen anscheinend, weiss man nur von dem Blutacker und dann haben beide mal ihre, ist wie so eine Reizwortgeschichte, Blutacker und Judas und Geld und Lothar und Matthäus haben einfach mal versucht, so ein bisschen ihre Fantasie freien Lauf zu lassen.
Die kamen wahrscheinlich beide einfach zu spät und mehr so wie Blutacker und denken sich, aber vor allem, weil, also, das macht ja, das ist ja auch eine ganz andere Moral der Geschichte, weil wenn man sagt, es ist die Bibel, haben diese Geschichten tatsächlich stattgefunden, ja, nein, egal, es geht darum, was man daraus lernt. Aber hier lernt man aus derselben Geschichte zwei völlig unterschiedliche Dinge.
In der Matthäus-Version heisst es, oh, wenn du was Falsches tust, dann wird dein eigenes Gewissen dich heimsuchen und du erhängst dich am Ende, also lass es. Und in der Lukas-Version heißt es, ja, Gott wird dich dafür bestrafen, wenn du was Gutes machst. Also zwei komplett widersprüchliche Auslegungen auch der gesamten Religion eigentlich, weil nach Matthäus heißt es, der Mensch ist in sich selber gut und merkt, wenn er was Falsches getan hat und versucht, Treue zu tun, gibt sein Geld wieder zurück und er hängt sich, weil er es bereut. Und in anderen Situationen, nee, fuck it, ich kaufe mir einen Acker, hab eine geile Zeit, aber dann falle ich um und wahrscheinlich ist es dann Gottes Strafe, dass er dann genau auf dem Acker, den er gekauft hat, stirbt. Also der Mensch ist nicht gut, sondern der Gott muss es richten. Also es ist völlig unterschiedliche Auslegungen. Ja, okay. Ja, muss ich so wütend werden. Aber ich bin auch schon mal fast so unglücklich gefallen, dass ich in zwei Hälften gebrochen bin. Muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Manchmal denkt man schon, beim Fallen denkt man dann schon, oh, nee, das geht nicht gut aus. Was war das für ein Acker? Also ich habe viel Zeit meiner Kindheit auf einem Acker verbracht, Bogenschiessen und Ritterspiele, aber also. Selbst beim Bogenschießen spielen kommt man selten in die Situation, wo man in zwei Hälften geteilt wird auf einem Acker. Ungünstig. Einfach zwei Teile zerbrochen. Ja, das stimmt. Aber das ist wirklich häufig mal so bei Bibelgeschichten, die kann man häufig in zwei komplett unterschiedlichen Wegen auslegen und so. Ich bin mir auch nicht sicher, ob Matthäus, Johannes und wie sie alle heissen, immer die gleichen Ideen hatten, auch von Gott und vom Christentum. Aber warum hat man das nicht irgendwann redigiert und gesagt, okay, Hilarius, es gibt ja eine Auslegung, entweder der Mensch ist gut oder Gott ist für den Menschen gut.
Und dann sagt man einfach, eines von beiden ist richtig, streicht das andere.
Ich glaube, Hilarius ... Hängt das hinten an den Anhang, das liest eh keiner.
Hilarius wollte es redigieren, aber da hat man gesagt, nee, komm.
Och, was hat er geschrieben mal hier?
Geht ein Rabbi, Jesus und Super Mario in eine Bar.
Alle, ach Gott, nee.
Er wollte es ja redigieren.
Ja, ja, ja. Sein Name wurde ihm zu vermitteln.
Er hat bestimmt auch viele Pranks mit diesen O-Platten gemacht oder so, dass die ganz salzig waren oder irgendwie, dass sie die dann irgendwie in den Pferdeurin getränkt hat und dann hi hi hi hi.
Hast du gegessen? Prankster, Prankster! Es ist kein Wein, es ist wirklich Blut. Der Prankpapst, das war auch mal eine gute Serie. Prankster. Könntest du dir das vorstellen, so eine Comedy-Serie über den Papst im fünften Jahrhundert zu schreiben? Ja, kann ich mir vorstellen, ich kann es mir nicht vorstellen, zu drehen, um ehrlich zu sein, da hält es dann bei mir auf. Das ist schon schwierig. Ich wüsste nicht wie. Man hat halt keine Ahnung, wie das damals aussah mit dem Papst und so, ne? Also, der sah bestimmt ganz anders aus. Ja, wahrscheinlich war die leicht anders verrutscht auf dem Kopf die Kappe. Sonst war aber alles andere gleich. Ich glaube nicht, dass es anders war, ehrlich gesagt. Ja, doch, es gibt ja in The Young Pope eine Szene, wo dem aktuellen Papst so im Traum oder in so einer Vision ganz viele andere Päpste erscheinen. Die stehen dann alle um den Tisch herum und die sehen alle anders aus, auch von ihrer Uniform oder von ihrem Gewand, sehen die alle anders aus und der eine dann halt so ganz mittelalterlich und dann ganz anders. Also anscheinend gibt es da auch so Trend empfehlen kann wie es dann anders aussieht ist auch the two popes heute ist die große papst folge the two popes auf netflix fand ich einen ganz tollen film nee kann ich nicht empfehlen ich fand ich fand ich gut okay da könnte er selber entscheiden ob er das gucken will oder nicht aber da ist ja auch was ja auch da offensichtlich wird ist dass, dass Päpste auch immer eine unterschiedliche Auffassung haben, auch wie sie rumzulaufen haben, denn der Papst Franziskus, der aus sehr bescheidenen, einfachen Verhältnissen kommt, anders als der deutsche Josef Ratzinger, der hat ja auch, als er sich dann präsentieren wollte dem Volke zum ersten Mal, ja auch auf alles verzichtet, auf die Papstschuhe verzichtet, auf diese meine ich ja roten Schuhe, er hat auf diesen Umhang, talarartigen Umhang verzichtet, den man sonst trägt zur Verzierung und so und ist halt so sehr einfach raus und hat auch einfach den Petersklassel mit Buonasera begrüsst und nicht irgendwie mit einem lateinischen Zauberspruch. Und das ist, glaube ich, auch einfach ein Zeichen dafür, wie man halt so ein Pontifikat auslegt. Das fand ich sehr spannend. Aber dieser Film hat ja nicht gefallen. Nee, aber haben wir eigentlich schon über John Mulaney in The Sacklunch Bunch gesprochen? Habe ich noch nicht gesehen. Oh, dann schaust du sie an. Das ist meine Empfehlung. Freue ich mich drauf. Auf Netflix John Mulaney in The Sacklunch Bunch gespielt habe ich noch nicht gesehen. Oh, dann schaust du dir an, das ist meine Empfehlung. Freue ich mich drauf.
Auf Netflix John Mulaney in the Sacklunch Bunch verbindet die zwei schönsten Dinge der Welt, Musicals und Kinder und verbindet sie in einer unwiderstehlichen Kombination zu diesem sehr, sehr lustigen, heiteren Melange an Musik und Tanz mit Jake Gyllenhaal. Und John Mulaney. Und ich finde es auch gut, dass er das gepitcht hat. Er hat bei Jimmy Fallon oder so das erzählt, dass er nicht wusste, wie er das pitchen sollte, weil er immer diese Idee hatte, aber ihm nie ganz klar war, was es überhaupt wird und wie man sich das überhaupt vorstellen soll, wie er es erklären soll. Und ich habe von sehr vielen Leuten schon gehört, dass sie es mir empfehlen, aber keiner konnte mir genau sagen, worum es geht und was es genau ist. Es sind singende Kinder. Es sind primär singende Kinder, was in mir nichts als, ja, nee, brauche ich nicht unbedingt gucken, auslöst. Ja, aber ich weiß nicht, bei mir funktioniert es immer. Kinder, die sich erwachsen verhalten, finde ich immer lustig. Jetzt singen, aber nicht das erwachsene Verhalten. Nee, aber natürlich sind viele Gags dann, dass die halt reifere Texte sagen, als sie in ihrem Alter angemessen werden. Und das finde ich, das ist einfach ein Gag, der immer bei mir funktioniert. Aber es ist auf jeden Fall sehr lustig, viele tolle Lieder und auch sehr catchy, also vieles ist mir da noch lange im Ohr geblieben. Also ein Hochgenuss für Jung und Alt, für Musicalfans. Aber wir wissen beide, dass in dem Moment, in dem ich es empfehle, ich dafür sorge, dass du es niemals anschauen wirst. Was bei dir nicht unbedingt stimmt. Du bist in meiner Liste von zwei Menschen, vielleicht drei Menschen, wo ich wirklich das gucke, was du empfiehlst. Aber es gibt manche, die wissen es auch nicht, aber Leute, mit denen ich auch sehr eng befreundet bin, die mir Dinge empfehlen die ganze Zeit und ich immer beim Zuhören auch sehr aufgeregt bin und sage, ja, oh wow, ja cool und es nie gucke. Ja, hast du schon Paddleton gesehen? Paddleton? Nein. Nein, habe ich letztes Jahr empfohlen. Paddleton, auch auf Netflix, toller Film. Vielleicht war der noch nicht auf Netflix oder so, vielleicht war der nicht so gut zu gucken. Und natürlich stefan.de. Wir wollen den Traffic auf stefan.de auf jeden Fall hochballern. Keep the traffic high auf stefan.de. Stimmt bei uns, für uns ab, beim Deutschen Podcastpreis. Habt eine ganz, ganz fantastische Woche. Wir hören uns nächste Woche, freue ich mich sehr drauf. Nächste Woche ist Berlinale, wo ich bin, wo ich mich sehr drauf freue. Zum ersten Mal bin ich da, da freue ich mich dann so ein bisschen Eindrücke zu sammeln. Also nächste Woche die grosse Berlinale-Woche. Da habe ich aber auch ein bisschen Bock auf Glitzer, Glamour, Behind-the-Scenes, Backstage-Talk. Ja, Volke Ludewig-Stefan ist da am Start und wird ein bisschen einfangen, wo denn so die Trends hingehen im Fernsehen, im Film, in der deutschen Filmlandschaft in den nächsten Jahren. Vielen, vielen Dank nochmal an Leander für das fantastische Intro.
Besucht ihn auf leander.de auch.
Auch vielen Dank an alle, die weiterhin Antenne Afrikas einschicken.
Nächste Folge werden wir wieder ein Antenne Afrika-Segment haben.
Bis dahin, haut rein, macht's gut, wir heben ab, ciao.
Und ciao, ciao.